ah your next roaster coming to the stage
is Hans Kim now Hans the stand-up can be
called it's been described as bizarre a
little bit little unorthodox a little
unconventional a little sometimes a
little bit wooden sometimes lacking
segways however nope that's all that I
got all right please water massage mr.
Hobbs Kim Lisa gentlemen what's up white
people sorry to interrupt your clan
meeting bellevue one the Bellevue
chapter drew barn drew Barth is so white
they use his face as a background for
speed limit signs jr. the only way chair
is gonna be funny of scientists figure
out how to eat laughter geração fat dumb
and white he's going to be on the new
confederate flag junior would be more
successful but his extra chromosome gets
in the way he looks so [ __ ] that one
of these grocery stores the clerks have
to ask him where his parents or
guardians are let's see I'm gonna look
at my notes
I'm super [ __ ] asian it's gonna be
here with Drupal Ralph Naren Lucas and
drew it's it's like the united nations
of midgets up here there are so many
lawn gnomes on this stage it looks like
Brooks childhood home Ralph is here he's
from Tacoma great comedian the only
reason why he's here today is because
he's so sure that the bullets all flew
over his head just like most of the
jokes tonight the only way to kill Ralph
is with the lawnmower you know you're
short when an agent calls you short the
only reason Ralph made it as a Tacoma
comp comedian is because he's so old and
black that he knows what it's like to
not get paid for the work you do
tyler smith smoked so much weed he's
become an honorary asian Tyler isn't a
real person he's a dare program
propaganda experiment that escaped Tyler
is such a lazy stoner you can't even
come up with his own ideas for shows he
stole them all and it was inside
baseball no one cares naren van deren
bands here aaron's bands face is so
scarred he looks like the thing from
Fantastic Four except with none of the
strength if you make out with Narron
you'll also get exfoliated if you want
to know what Mars looks like just make
Noren blush Lucas seelies producer of
the big sky comedy festival that's great
he brags about how he has the agents
from come on Comedy Central and NBC
there why don't use them yeah your
career is going nowhere Lucas works out
because if he didn't horny white men
would try to finger his butthole all the
time now I get to choose which white
person figures his bubble Lucas looks
like a child sex slaves on steroids
that's for me all right Brooke Fox
Brooke Fox is here this lady I've never
met before she's such a stereotypical
white mom she cooks more tofu than my
family Brooke is so white but she still
can't keep Jose from getting shot
listening to Brooke kowtow to Jubal and
Jose has set feminism back more than the
new Ghostbuster movie instead of raising
the roof why don't you try to raise the
glass ceiling all right she's so white
that the only reason she's here is try
to get one of the asians to fix your
phone right onto the star of the show
Jubal like with everything else there's
someone more important than you here
Jose there's 2 g's in his name because
he likes being called names with 2 g's
in it like [ __ ] your face looks like a
scrotum what does your scrotum look like
if you listen carefully to his radio
show you can hear his eyes getting
further apart Jubal is as respected in
the comedy community as much as he's
respected in his pickup basketball
community Jose Jose is here it's true
Wow in a man's body Jose is like the
Mexican Joker but like everything
Mexican is not as good as a drinking
problem as it has a problem managing his
money Jose seems like the type of guy
who would be in a frat if he wasn't so
Mexican last time we did this show it
took a week to get the stench of Axe
body spray out of this room and another
week to file all the date-rape
complaints sorry I even Jose's hair
doesn't want to be a part of his career
how does a belief Jose believes in the
American dream so much he became bald
and fat they call movin 92.5 movin 92.5
because everyone who listens to it wants
to move Jose laugh so loud because it's
hard to be heard with Jubal's balls in
your mouth all right that's what I thank
guys
here we go for Hans Kim lays to German
Hans Kim is a mighty cool novelty beard
he's rocking awesome I love it next
comic coming up to the stage a lot of
people talked about seriously one of the
best dressed people I have ever seen in
Seattle comedy every time I see him it
looks like he walked just right out of a
catalog full-size and